sabemos que esta vez en alemania por
primera vez hay una gran cantidad de
gente que votó por coreo y esto en
algunos circunscripciones es encima de
60 por ciento casi estos correos
necesitan más tiempo para ser contados y
por eso fue decretada esta mañana que
sabíamos con exactitud con certeza cuál
será el resultado bueno estas elecciones
tienen una característica particular y
es que se van a necesitar al menos tres
partidos en coalición para lograr una
mayoría en el parlamento con ese
panorama que tanta fuerza cobran
movimientos como los verdes los
liberales o la izquierda
la izquierda es el único partido
progresista que ha perdido en estas
elecciones
creo que en general se puede decir que
hay un aire de cambio en alemania en los
partidos progresistas la
socialdemocracia las verdes han
aumentado y también el partido liberal
que hizo una campaña hacia la
moralización nació un cambio entonces
esta opción de cambio realmente fue la
que aumentó los que perdieron eran los
conservadores del partido de angela
merkel que en comparación con 2017
bajaron 30 pues de un 30 por ciento más
a 20 por ciento eso definitivamente no
es una victoria entonces los partidos
verdes y liberales son las que entren
ahora con un grande ventaja en las lo
que llamamos los sondeos las charlas de
sondeo y luego las negociaciones de
coaliciones
sabemos que américa latina no es un
punto principal en la agenda de política
exterior de alemania pero que podría
venir para la región con el nuevo
ejecutivo
yo creo que hay una cierta estabilidad
yo ojalá que la nueva configuración
en alemania puede tocar los tres grandes
desafíos que tiene alemania que es
principalmente la descarbonización
luego la lucha contra sus desigualdades
y tercero
reestablecer la confianza de los
ciudadanos en un estado resiliente y eso
ojalá lo haría otra vez una
fuerza potente dentro de la unión
europea
creo que hay algunas diferencias entre
las distintas opciones de coalición es
una coalición en liderazgo del pd junto
con los verdes y los liberales podría
ser más progresista también en el ámbito
de la política exterior económica eso es
muy importante dentro de la unión
europea creo que allí había ciertos
descontentos y problemas con la polis
económica de austeridad de angela merkel
dentro de
los países en deuda en alemán en la
unión europea entonces ahí esta opción
progresista que sería quizás también
avanzando un poquito más rápido en el
cambio
de
pena de la crisis climática eso podría
ser un nuevo aliado progresista para
américa latina al contrario una opción
una coalición
liderado por los conservadores
seguramente seguirá con un curso más
tradicional en términos de economía y
quizás un poco menos enfocado en el
estado de bienestar y con conceptos
tradicionales
bueno señor abrir que daniels a usted
muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos en
france 24 y compartirnos este análisis